I was likely to be caught napping in
between scenes is me I'm all about that
napping life
Felicity has that strength definitely
Felicity a lot of people don't know she
kind of like grew up doing horse riding
woodwork and archery kind of survival
school stuff so she's kind of a military
badass
felicity mainly because she's good with
sticks and she'll smack smack you down
she upset her that is she's a leader I
think this the biggest Star Wars nerd
will find is actually not someone of the
course is the director it's Gareth
Edwards a complete fanboy Gareth Edwards
Gareth Edwards Gareth Edwards because
Gareth Edwards he knew everything
there was a competition between alan
tudyk and gareth edwards some would
probably say me but I'm gonna say Ben
Mendelsohn
I mean it has to be Donnie Yen me in
Middleton I did a few I have to admit
now that I can and that they cannot cut
me out of the film I did take a lot
raise let's just say R is even though
it's probably not raised well on say
actually we weren't allowed phones so
you couldn't take selfies actually we
could have to do is when the costume or
continuity people were taking photos of
you as a reference on your costume you'd
have to just be like take sensible takes
that to me later probably be Diego with
you know tequila or mezcal involved at
some point I would say Diego Luna would
initiate the hangout it would never take
place but he'd initiate it
I am qualified to take that one yes
not true it's true yeah I had the the
the difficult task of being next to Alan
Tudyk that is so much fun and and he
just can't stop so he makes it very
difficult for those around him well
anything with it with Diego Alan and I
it was very hard to keep a straight face
and there would be a lot of trying to
kind of hold onto your cheeks as well as
your laughing too much
Jang when is most likely to nail the
scene on the first take
probably Mads she's such a good actor
but I never worked with him but that
would be dir Diego I have to say Darth
Vader you know I don't want him to look
at this interview and not be mentioned
I might start going Oh God so Darth
Vader probably Forest Whitaker partly
because he's Forest Whitaker and he
comes in with the ridiculous level of
preparation but also because he Forest
Whitaker so good luck to the person who
goes to tell him he has to do it again
alan alan tudyk and he gets away with it
for some reason alan tudyk again yeah
I should really manage alan tudyk and
launch him as a stand-up comedian alan
tudyk insane I do a pretty good Diego
Luna Alan I have to tell you the whole
crew is very sad now one day he was yeah
he was doing my voice and it was quite
scary